- We're ready to jump.
One, two, three!
(energetic music)
We're here at the MuckFest MS Mud Run.
It's an event to raise money
for the National MS Society
and help people fight MS
and end the disease forever.
- [Voiceover] I'm ready to win,
I'm going to win this thing.
- Well, you know, it's a charity mud run.
You don't need to win.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
I'm going to beat Ned at this.
- That's fine. That's fine.
We've got a whole crew, my wife is here.
There's so many people that
have come out to support
whether it be runners or
volunteers or staff members.
Hello!
What does this event mean to you?
- I have MS, so this is
very meaningful to me.
- One of my best friends has
MS and I do it for the cause.
- [Man] We are here with...
- Teresa Caceres.
- [ Man] We actually
were running next to them
for like half of the Mud Run, right.
- Yes, I was diagnosed with MS in 2007.
I get numbness and
tingling, I get vertigo,
I had symptoms for about 7 years
and had no idea what it was.
Doctors said I was fine,
nothing's wrong with me
and I was adamant and I kept
just going back to the doctor
until finally they gave me an MRI
and that's what diagnosed me.
- Because this really
could afflict anybody.
- It could.
I lost all mobility in my right arm,
I couldn't pick up a pen.
It happened right after I had my son.
It was pretty horrible.
- But I just saw you swinging across ropes
and running through like muddy obstacles.
You're definitely kicking
MS's butt for sure.
- I sure am kicking MS's butt.
So is my daughter and so
is the 25 members who came.
- And I just love that all of
my friends have come together.
- Everyone is super enthusiastic,
I absolutely love the energy,
everyone is just ready to get all dirty.
- [Voiceover] It means the
world, you're doing something fun
just to continue the research of something
that can help millions of people.
It's the world to me.
- What was the most
difficult obstacle for you?
- The one across the lake,
that was really cool.
Just walking over, jumping
over barrels, that was fun.
- [ Voiceover] The one
where we, like, held on.
It was like a zipline.
- [ Voiceover] Oh the zipline ring.
- [Voiceover] I did a front flip
into the water at that point.
- [Voiceover] Being tagged
and then being tackled.
- [Voiceover] The general rope net climb.
- What was that like?
- It was easy.
- I mean the reason I come here is because
I love laughing, I love seeing
my dad run through the mud
and just the laughter
everyday gets me through.
- Do some research, realize
that it affects so many people.
MS Society has their website,
you can also look up MuckFest
MS, it's all over the country.
- We just did a Mud Run, thanks so much
to the National MS Society.
For everyone that wants to
fight MS, we are The Try Guys!
Argh, get muddy!
Get muddy!
- I'm just giving you a sexy water bath.
(energetic, rhythmic rock music)
- Why wash your butt alone
when you can wash your butt with friends?
(laughter)